وقالت الجريده الوقائع المصريه الرسميه
محكمه جددت ادراج عشرات الاشخاص بينهم
صحفيون بشبكه الجزيره على قوائم الارهاب
لخمس سنوات اخرى
لقد عبرنا عن قلقنا بشان وضع الصحفيين
بمنفهم صحفي الجزيره في مصر ونحن نكرر هذه
المخاوف فان حبسه واحتجاز الصحفيين الذين
يقومون بعمل سلمي بالالتزام بالمعايير
الدوليه امر لا يمكن او لا يجب ان يحصل
نحن نعرف انه في مصر اليه توجيه تهمه
الارهاب القانون العقوبات قانون مناهضه
الارهاب تساء استخدامها لتوجيه التهم او
للضغط على الوضع فاعين عن حقوق الانسان
ويتم اعاده تدوير التهمه ان صح القول من
اجل ابقاء هؤلاء في السجن
[موسيقى]
عاده تستخدم القوانين بطريقه غير مقبوله
من اجل اسكاتي الصحفيين وهذا امر غير
مقبول هذه الافعال غير الديمقراطيه هي
تنتهي كافه مبادئ حقوق الانسان هذا
التجديد لهذه اللائحه الارهاب التي كانت
سوف
ينتهي العمل بها امر غير مقبول امر لا
يحتمل
[موسيقى]
الحكومه المصريه عليها
تعترف
بمشروعيه عمل المدافعين عن حقوق الانسان
بموجب الالتزامات التي تقع عليها لمجرد
انها عضو في منظمات الوان المتحده كافه
المدافعين عن حقوق الانسان شو اطلاق
سراحهم وكل هؤلاء الصحفيين الذين كان
يمارسون حريه التعبير وحق التعبير عن
النفس وعن ارائهم بكل سلميه يجب ان يطلق
سراحهم انا ادين مع قامت به السلطات
المصريه لادراج صحفيين على قائمه الارهاب
لا سيما صحفيه الجزيره وهما ايضا مسجونان
في مصر هذا
اساءه استخدام
لمصطلح الارهاب
[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان ما يجب القيام به هو ان قوانين
مكافحه الارهاب وقانون العقوبات بامس
الحاجه الى اصلاحات